mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
i'm thinking of a two-digit number
if i write three to the left of my
number and double
this three-digit number the result is 27
times my original number
what is my number a version of this
problem
was asked to 14 and 15 year old students
in the belgian mathematical olympiad
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
suppose by number has the digits of a
and
b algebraically this will be equal to 10
times
a plus b suppose i write 3
to the left of this number the result
will be 300 plus 10 a plus b
we want to double this number and then
we will distribute the 2.
it'll be equal to 600 plus 20a
plus 2b this is equal to 27
times my original number we then want to
solve this equation
we'll first distribute the 27 and then
we will collect like terms
we then divide both sides of this
equation by 25
and we get 24 is equal to 10 a plus b
but recall 10 a plus b is my original
number therefore
my original number was equal to 24 and
that's the answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
see you next episode as we continue to
solve the world's problems
one video at a time
you